Oh Khloe blowy yes my name is markiplier
and welcome to bloodbath babe
now bloodbath Bay is a horror game to be
sure will you have to go diving down
into the depths of the ocean and face
some of my worst nightmares I don't know
exactly what's waiting for me down there
at the bottom of the ocean but I have a
bad feeling that it's going to be
something horrible and something that's
probably gonna kill me dad which is very
likely Donnie
alright I don't need to remind anyone of
the importance regarding this up we'll
be on extraction good hunting down wait
I think you need to remind me of what
the hell's going on down here it was
like something from a damn horror show
what was what she's were climbing out of
their graves and feasting on the living
diving so low could be considered one of
the more reckless things a person for
such a thing so stupid the more I'm a
doing a situation it almost felt safer
down here peacefully the calm before a
storm well don't say that I don't like
this I don't like this at all I
definitely do not like this yeah I also
don't like the perspective it's making
it thing seem like there's things in the
darkness yeah
do I need to be worried about that
should I shoot that I only got so many
bullets should I be worried about that
okay now this game is made by okay
remember we're after those glowing sea
snails we briefed you on earlier we're
going to need no less than about thirty
of those little buggers a successful
treatment why I had written the dossier
these snails weren't usually so easy to
find something about their mating season
drove them from the rocks glowing bright
to attract a mate
little wobbly Matty I had my own reasons
for taking on this job what are your
reasons what are your reasons sir okay I
got one snail yeah I got a snail
everybody be happy about the snail I got
is everybody ecstatic about the snail
all right now I don't know for a fact if
there are things in the deep dark news
here but I have a funky feeling I have a
funky feeling whoa hey Nemo I have a
funky feeling that if I find them
they're gonna be crawling on my butt any
mama now that looks bad why am i
governess why me why would I be going
this way why did I choose to do this
also where am i oh I know where I am
okay all right but I haven't ooh that
was not enough spirit that was not
enough sprinty do
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay yeah god I gotta find 30 of these
[ __ ] or maybe that was three and I
was just hearing things maybe I may be
hearing things when they're coming after
me in the darkness but I do not like the
way the world just warps around over
those piranhas no no Donny we're picking
up that you are nearing the proximity to
the Santa and adults during the war this
area was host to some intense naval
skirmishes I know you're working with
low visibility but you might come across
some leftover sea mines if you do they
can be set as checkpoints seeing you so
many lives were lost logo started
calling the area bloodbath bag okay all
right yeah a checkpoint that'll do me a
lot of good I'm real happy about the
fact that I have checked boy what's down
here in the death area
I see Chloe's hey hey ba I don't like
that no I said to have been Duke all
right don't mind me is that a pirate
ship bye-bye there we go oh okay guess
he's not lethal all right well that's
not good
all right just gonna skedaddle around
that and go for the glowy and I saw over
here somewhere
Chloe's gone okay Oh Khloe blowy yes
[Music]
that's a lot of moaning oh good okay
okay I saw another one over here
Oh God okay I don't know where it went
but it's very gone it is exceptionally
gone okay I guess I'm fine
I thought I saw something who are you
you okay
alright maybe I'm out of amount of gun
I'm out of gun and maybe the best option
is just a run as far as I can run why
are you that why oh that's why Chloe
yeah Yahoo I can kind of see them on the
mini-map so that's good I guess
[Music]
don't like that hey-ho no no 100 ie ie
ie no don't please I'm too young I'm
okay look at checkpoint oh ah you meant
that literally you meant literally their
checkpoints I thought you just met there
were like no I thought you just meant
that they were landmarks okay alright
well now one god 4:30
oh now I'm seeing more of them where
were all them before all right whatever
hope you know that did not work well oh
I'm dead again thank you okay alright I
don't think I need to press X to escape
but you know I'll keep that in mind you
never gonna go away
I saw
I tried my best I tried my best
can you imagine being down here in the
dark depths of the ocean hidden away
from absolutely everything all you see
is darkness can what do you want me to
play with the controller
I'll do that how do i sprint whoa what
the heck e nice roll there bud I don't
know how to sprint what I know how to
combat roll and to be perfectly honest
that's probably just as important I
can't run no idea I have no idea how to
run ice well there we go I got a push
down oh hey buddy hey grouper Hey look I
see a shiny hmm
how do I need 30 of these [ __ ]
there's no way [ __ ] that's my life [ __ ]
how do I do that okay you are a bag of
tits and I dog oh no I'm triple whammy
try not to imagine they are in the
darkest deepest depths of hell this game
you can't win you can't win them
flailing like a [ __ ] every time I get
snapped up in the jaws of the [ __ ]
fish if my pathetic combat role ain't
gonna do [ __ ] to me it's like my worst
nightmare wrapped up in a nightmare
burrito oh my god I can only hope that
it's not directly in front of me maybe I
could just afford the opportunity to
roll into its mouth that the only thing
that I can play for here maybe it's
gonna be nice and swallow me whole be
careful I might roll away from you oh
that's a problem didn't even have an
opportunity to let me suck you're just
gonna let me squander around and fear
and then die on my own you bag of dough
oh you big honking honking bag it's a
fireman I mashed as hard as I could
it's the sucker face god
he's got no face oh well my thing I
think I'm probably boy boy guys I don't
want to brag but I think I'm doing
pretty good huh I don't want to go out
on a limb here but we get a roll for the
bushes oh there we go stop chomping on
the crotch like that please I don't know
I'm going exactly the way you were going
so that's unfortunate for the both of us
go back now because apparently I was
going the wrong way no matter what thank
you yes please yes okay thank you
oh hey running roll rolling run those
are the only two skills that I know and
neither of them are working it's still
behind me isn't it roll into the bushes
you're so weird
okay I guess we're fine then I have no
idea when my webcam broke I have no
[ __ ] idea but my just wait what wait
what wait wait hang on a second second
here wait hey God I think there's some I
don't think that's now that looks like a
foot I don't think I seem to be
permanently dead and mr. blubber face
off all right wait
I guess that's enough for a bloodbath
BAE the game that's pretty difficult I
don't know how you'd get all of these
things at the same time but that is
bloodbath Bay thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to play it
for yourself check it out in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments and as
always I will see you in the next
bye-bye
[Music]